- [Mark] If one of your girls wants out,
she just decided she's done
with his life and wants to quit.
Is that an option for her?
Okay, I'm sorry.
What's your name again?
- You can call me Nico
Cucuz any one or two.
I go by any one of them.
- All right.
Where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I grew up in Memphis Tennessee.
- And tell me about
your family growing up.
You had both your parents.
- Yeah, I had both of my parents
and I lost my dad, you know, too
he had heart trouble and you know,
and my momma she stayed
strong as a black lady
and she came and tried to
continue to do the base.
And you, me and my sister, a good life
it's like 13 of us,
but my other brothers in Chicago
they chose to stay up there.
You know what I'm saying?
So me and my sisters
came, we, we stayed here.
We didn't leave.
- Yup.
And how far did you go in school?
- I made it to the 11th grade.
I got kicked out because, you know,
I started early, like you know,
I started early
easy fast money, you know?
And if you from Memphis,
you've immediately
just me making easy money
and pimping hoes in style.
So, you know, this had come about.
So it ain't no reason
why I person should say
he's not there or things ain't, you know,
to your ability in Memphis
because Memphis is a distribution
so everything has to come through here.
So it's kind of easy to kind of catch on.
Then, you know, me being so
young and I'm in the streets
I put everything else on the back burner
and went straight forward with, you know
pimping hoes and all it,
you know what I'm saying?
And then
I kinda,
you know,
made my momma and daddy
smile before he left.
I went and got my GED,
you know what I'm saying?
And I went from there and and
like I said
earliest like 16 years old.
I hit my first hoe at 16.
- Who, who taught you the game?
Really, I came in like, you know
I came in, you know, when
you, when you in the streets
and you move around and big
dogs see potential in you
they kind of put you under their wing
it's just kinda like
a, a father, son thing.
If you got a good night into the street
you see what I'm saying?
And when I came about,
you know what I'm saying?
Cause I wasn't even old enough
to get in the strip club.
You see what I'm saying?
But my face card was so good.
I just won't clean through, you know
there ain't no ID, no surgery, no nothing.
And I went straight in and
when I went straight in
you know, I knocked the
first hoe that night
was Kiki, paradise.
There was us streets day
and night in paradise.
And it was a guy by the name of Freestyle.
You know what I'm saying?
And freestyle took me under his wings,
he had like six hoes.
You know what I'm saying?
He took me under his wings and he
showed me where I went wrong and
showed me what I don't do.
And he's like,
when,
because when you when you
come about with the game
of pimping or whatever
because if this hoe
belongs to somebody else
but then she wanted to
leave them and come to you.
You can't do that because it's not right.
You have to get her and
him and you have to go.
It's a word called serve.
I like you, serve.
Like it just like, you
get kicked out your house,
and they have to serve you your papers
for you to leave and get evicted.
So I had to go get up.
I didn't know this.
I had to take her,
me,
I had to go to him and
serve him and let him know
that this is no longer your hoe.
She belongs to me.
She pays me.
- You have to pay, pay him to tell
- Nah, she pays me.
I just had to serve him and let him know
as of this hour this day and entity.
But don't say nothing to her.
Don't put your hands on her.
You can just scratch her off your roster
because she's no longer your hoe.
She chose me
She chose me.
She walked in and sit
down for about an hour.
She walked in and sat
on my lap and told me
I'd been watching you
since you came in here.
And she said, I want to go home with you.
I said, baby, I don't do that
Cause you know, to me
being a young street n****
I kind of thought it
was like a setup thing
because she just came out of the blue
and came telling me she
wanted to go home with me
and all these rooms.
And she's a pretty looking girl.
So I know she got a pimp.
So I'm thinking it's the game.
You see what I'm saying?
But the whole time she
was on some really wants
she sees potential in me.
So she gave me her money bag,
you know the little
things in the strip club.
They had these little
bags around they wrist
with they money.
She took it off and handed it to me.
And I went and served,
and from that day forward
that was my first hoe.
They were
they were my very first hoe
and I was 16 years old.
Real talk.
- How many girls do you have now?
- I have like,
really,
to be honest,
I had like six girls, right?
But when I had like my
bottom, my bottom girl and
two other girls,
they make more noise
than ten girls together.
So I don't need all the hassle.
I got three main lines and
they, they, they, they work
and and you would think I got
14, 15 hoes way they move.
You see what I'm saying?
- How much does each
girl bring in a night?
- Probably,
on a slow night,
we probably do like
on a slow night.
Because I tell them 3 dates, we ate
That's my motto.
Three dates on a slow day, we ate.
Because if you charging 450
just for a conversation.
So when they get on to want to do details
and seem noisy and do all that extra stuff
it's about an hour
and my girl, they not cheap.
They 350 or better, you
see what I'm saying?
So on a, on a bad night, I
probably would do like 2,500.
You know what I'm saying?
And I bet in my home boy,
cause he was like,
man you ain't taking
2,500 out the city man
without getting on the computer.
You know without--
See they be going up and down the highway.
You see what I'm saying?
But I turned my girls
on to this thing called
sugardaddy.com.
And they made a lot of trees
but they were not considered trees.
They were like, they clients.
And they were like in on sugardaddy.com.
You tell a little bit about yourself
and what you're looking for.
And these guys already
on there looking for
certain things and ain't no bullshit.
Like everybody on there really papered up.
Like, ain't no.
Like you sitting there talking to a man.
He tell you, "Well go to the airport.
I'm gonna give you and send you a ticket.
I'm on my yacht.
They're going to drop you off in Florida.
And I'd be at the Harbor to pick you up",
That type of shit.
That's how they get down.
They rich, they,
they don't,
know what I'm saying?
Like my girl named Ms. Behave.
She had a old, she got
an old dude named Jim.
They kind of tied in
with like the Chik-fil-a.
She like, he a Jew.
You know what I'm saying?
It might get her 500 just to
come out there to the car.
When he pulled up,
pulled her shirt up,
let her see her titties and he gone.
- So $2,500 a night
all three of your girls will bring in
or each one?
- Nah, on a bad,
you said on a slow night.
- Yeah.
- Like 2,500 I'd be cool with it
- Without each girl?
- But nah each girl, probably,
the minimum, like 1200 and you cool.
It's like
it ain't picking up beat is what?
You just, just stay out there
and try least make a
thousand dollars, man.
Cause we got to go forward.
We can't go backwards.
So we got a thousand and we put it up.
We can think about things.
We can make plans now.
It ain't no minimum,
we, we trying to do it big a little bit.
Like, you know, thinking
about tomorrow and all that
we ain't thinking about today.
You see what I'm saying?
- Different races of girls.
- Nah I had, I got, I had
at one bilingual girl.
She was she Vietnamese and black,
you know?
But she ended not wanting
her grandma to see.
So he ended up going back
to Vietnam with her grandma.
You know what I'm saying?
But when she comes to the Cedar,
she come home
you know what I'm saying?
But she just,
you know,
like you consider her like a six man.
She is needed.
You see what I'm saying?
She's on the bench until you need.
Like, we don't really even
think of none of that.
But when she come home
she still come and
contribute to the campaign.
You know what I'm saying?
We just straight profit ENT this is mine.
This is me.
You know what I'm saying?
- Do you have sex with your girls?
- My main, man.
You know, then my main man,
because one thing about it.
If a n**** get to have
too much sex with them
they'll get to get feelings
like we girlfriend and
boyfriend and which we not.
We are what you consider
business partners.
So the night I'm gone, try to,
you know,
I ain't gonna say it ain't
never I almost went there
but I had the catch myself.
Because if
this what its about.
DNL used to get to get mislead because
they're thinking well I don't
get his money and all that
but I come home and, and
do this and do that he'll
forget about it and all that.
You know what I'm saying?
He ain't going to be so hard on me.
Cause this is my dude.
Nah, you see you got to keep
me with a beating and mind.
If I don't come home with this money,
I'm gonna get fired.
How I'm gonna feed my kids?
You know, as long as
you keep them on they 10
and all that.
Feelings and shit don't get
to getting watered down.
It stays the same.
You see what I'm saying?
But if you get them having
sex with all of them.
You know how it go.
You giving them good sex
and feelings come about.
And you don't want them to have feelings.
Like I don't want to do
with him and all that
cause this is what they is,
they a hoe,
they lay on their back for money.
They talk to him out of money.
Whatever it is they'll come from a client.
This is how you get it.
So like I said, at the end of the day
you can't stick the dick
in everything that you
consider your hoe because
they will be misled.
And they won't be about what
you want them to be about.
As long as you keep them on game
and teach them this and teach
them this and teach them this
they learn.
And so they feel like a
child going to school.
He gonna lead it to his
teacher because he's learning
and succeeding.
So if don't keep up with the game,
its paying off every time,
every time she feels like she's,
I'm the I'm the tree of life.
You see what I'm saying?
She coming back home for more and more
and she's you know,
she going, she going
to ride it out with me
cause it was from the bottom to the top.
- So the girl gives you all the money.
- She gives me everything
and then she'd be like
well I need to take my kids this and this.
We sit down and make a lease.
You know, you took this at the pot
You took this out of the pot.
You took this at the pot.
Like these, this month is Christmas.
So everything they took
out the pot to go Christmas
shopping and all that
is being tallied up.
You see what I'm saying?
So it ain't no walking around here
with a big bank roll and like, nah.
It's needed.
You see what I'm saying?
So it's true.
Even to go Christmas
shopping, here you go 500.
There's more than enough.
So I'm expecting, you'll be it.
Ain't no receipts coming back
with no hella numbers on it.
I'm expecting some change back.
You know what I'm saying?
So as long as they come
back with the receipts and
they add up, I'm cool with it.
You know what I'm saying?
And it just did on it.
You see what I'm saying?
- And then the laws have
changed in this game.
So it's a much more dangerous
thing for you, right?
- Exactly
- You've done prison time?
- Yes.
- What for?
- For my main thing was
I'm very, very laid back.
You know what I'm saying?
But this is why you see me now.
My company and my circle
has gotten so small.
because when I was around so many dudes
I constantly was getting
knocked out by the police
the narcotics and narcotic.
They call him to come and hit my spot.
But then because I was sneak,
straddling the fence
I was still selling drugs and pimping.
So I'm pivoting,
but I'm selling drugs.
So when they come in and out,
you know what I'm saying?
They think, and then now
they got the conclusion
that I'm pimping
but then I got a whore house going on
but really it's drugs being sold
And so they come in,
you know what I'm saying?
And I done got knocked out plenty of times
a hundred thousand bond, 250.
Oh no, I had to sit down
for like two years it's just
I done been through it.
So now, I just keep it like this
basic and discreet
you know what I'm saying?
My hoes, they go out of
town, they get they business
license, which mean
they go to a legal state
where prostitution is legal,
there's no problem.
The main thing is
here.
But they got some found
They got shit so laid
down with the blueprint
in like Vegas and all that
they got regulars.
So they go up there and do their thing.
You know what I'm saying,
do they thing.
It's nothing straight or drive.
You know what I'm saying?
And get their money.
And they come back like
on a vacation type shit
You know what I'm saying?
They'd gone back,
but all through the city I have never
like my hoes have been
caught up for prostitution
but it's not no regular thing.
Cause I don't have streetwalkers.
I don't have girls put
on heels and go out there
and walk the streets.
They on another level with it,
you see what I'm saying?
They phone ringing
people calling, demanding them.
We're questioning them.
You see what I'm saying?
So you know, other than that, it's like.
- Your, your girls use drugs.
- No, I'd say I keep them.
I keep them clean.
Because if you have a girl on
drugs her mind ain't stable.
Her man is not where you want it to be.
And then you trying to keep
on gang and tell her these.
But yeah, you did it, but the drugs
you don't make her feel like the drugs.
So she really not listening to you.
She hunting it for the drugs now.
So if you let her get addicted to drugs,
you making the mistake.
because she's not hustling to please you.
She's hustling to make
sure she keeps some dope.
And that ain't what's going on.
You see what I'm saying?
Dope makes hoes have cloudy minds.
They can't think right,
and stable and locked tight.
This is how you want them out.
Them girls on drugs and
shooting up and nah.
Nah this, this is a whole nother chapter
and I ain't with that.
I'm just gonna be honest.
- If, if one of your girls wants out
she just decided she's done
with his life and wants to quit.
Is that an option for her?
- I ain't going to say I'm
going to be hard on them.
If a girl come tell me right now
you now.
Cucuz I didn't, you know, I've
been doing this for 2 years.
I just really wanted to
now just go get me a job
and go raise my kids.
You know what I'm saying?
I got a heart too cause I got kids.
So I'm not going to tell her,
"Bitch, nah hoe you gonna go
do this! Bitch you aint gone"
Nah I ain't gone do none of that.
I don't use these.
I used this.
You see what I'm saying?
So if a day when she went out
and she has helped me and helped me do it,
I can't knock her,
have a busy life.
I appreciate you and
everything you have done for me
and she's gone, you know what I'm saying.
It's not no blood in and blood out thing
because you got people
they got changed lives.
They want to go home and
be a mother to they family.
So you can't fault them for that.
And I feel like if this is what you want
you being very, very stubborn,
you know what I'm saying?
And then because you had a good life
and you wanted your momma.
So why you think the kids
don't want their momma?
you already being stubborn having her
away from her needs at home.
So you kinda got the fault yourself.
- But even if she doesn't
have kids and just wants out
- Nah, if she don't have
kids and just want out
I still kind of straddle the fence
because if she's on a positive road,
like she's sick of this
they want to go get a degree and all that.
There's all types of other things
the person wanting to do
besides hoeing and doing
all this such thing.
So, you can't just say
what a person wants to do
but it's a problem.
She tell me she going to leave me for him
or him and him because he's,
I brought you to where you is,
hoe you weren't nothing without me.
So now I get you looking good.
And now you won't leave me
thought you're going
to go through another.
I ain't never had that
problem because I lead.
I'm a, I'm a great leader.
You see what I'm saying?
I'm a very great leader,
which means that
as long as you're a great leader,
you gonna forever have followers.
You see what I'm saying?
And this how it go.
You know what I'm saying?
- What, what are you
proudest of in your life?
What are you proudest of in your life?
- My success like how like, like, like
for Thanksgiving we just gave
away turkeys and all that.
You see what I'm saying?
My contributes back to the projects
in the hood because I ain't gonna lie.
I can't say I just had no rough life
but I didn't have no rich and famous life.
So I know how people out here struggling.
And I have a heart
and I'm thankful for the heart I have
and a lot of people I help.
I'm just not taking from society.
Cause I consider myself
a player or a pimp.
This just the way I
managed to get my money,
but I also help and all the other things.
So I'm just not getting
the money and on some,
"Hoe fuck you bitch this is my money hoe,
you can't get none."
No, I'm very grateful then.
I had to grab a good heart.
You know what I'm saying?
And I'm not gonna down and talk all bad
and none of this and all that uh.
I'm just proud of the person I became,
because I could have went left
because drugs had started
being a part of my life
at one point in time.
But I started losing more.
So I had to like,
it's like,
if I'm going to be stay
focused and stay clean
and do my thing this is
what I'm going to do.
But if not, you're going
to lose everything.
So I had to stand firm.
And when I, when I kicked it out,
it hurt for a minute because
it would it make you feel good.
But one thing that this,
this, this motto right here
I keep in my head and to
never go back that way.
It hurts so bad, but it feels so good.
Meaning the dope have you feeling great,
but it hurts so bad because
it brings up happy homes,
your family, and all that.
But you so gone off the
dope and feeling good.
You ain't even thinking about the them.
Fuck them you're thinking
about your next high.
Nah, I can't do that.
I got, I got other people depending on me.
So this is the way I
that's the way I had to
you know plant my roots
and not let them grow.
Anything successful, I'm with it.
I ain't, I ain't, I'm not on it.
Like I'm not on it.
I can't be on it because I have kids
and they love they daddy and all of that.
- Are you raising your kids
- Nah, they with their
mother, but I'm in their life.
I take care of my kids.
They're not wanting for anything.
- You, you been in love before?
- Yeah. As a young one.
And then like, like right
now, love is not a thing that
- Money's more important?
- No, because money ain't everything.
Love don't love nobody though.
And is such thing now
is loyalty over love.
I'd rather you be loyal to me,
then just come and scream you love me.
Cause as long as you're loyal to me
you're going to do all the
things they love makes you do.
Do you see what I'm saying?
So loyalty is the L word I use not love.
- Have you been doing this?
How old are you now?
- I'm 35.
- You've been doing it since 16?
How has the game changed?
- Tremendously, because
you get young girls
running away from home,
trying to do these and live out the age.
And then at one point in
time you had to show your ID
and all that.
Now they don't even care,
she say she want to do this then
they let him come along
and it's hurting the game
because it's making it hard on the people
that it's going the right way
about the things that they do.
And they feel like everybody
is screaming P they evil
and all of that.
And it's not right.
They just looking at the people
that put the bad jacket on that back.
So we had to, you know,
it did have to go straight
and fall in and do it firm and
make people a strong believer
that it is a everybody that
do this is not a bad person.
You know what I'm saying?
And everybody had do this and go this way.
They're not a killer or,
or the devil and all that
because I don't think like
him, I don't act like him.
I think like myself and
I make my own decisions.
So, you know, other than it, the game
the game ain't really changed.
It's just the people in it.
You know what I'm saying?
Exactly.
- What's the most important
lesson you've learned
in your life?
- Speak like others, but
I always have my mind
my own main idea and think like myself.
Because if I let you see my hand,
I ain't bluff you out.
But if I speak like you,
you thinking I get probably the same thing
and you ain't got a winner
but the whole time I got a flush
Ain't that what y'all call it in poker.
So he's really like,
I'm not tricking you,
but I'm really not going
to show you my hand
because I can't.
This is like, we, we, we, we
we battled with a like,
like, like Family Feud is on.
We call him to give him answers.
And then like, we each both
trying to get their money.
But every time a question asked
I gave you the answer
and I get the answer.
So both of us get the answer right.
Nah, there got to be a wrong and a right.
You see what I'm saying?
Both of us can't answer
the question right.
One of them might either
answer the question
and their answer is,
bring more points than
the quick answer you get,
but you still get it right.
And you thought like yourself so,
you should feel good in yourself
that didn't nobody help
you do this or nothing.
They just came about on your own.
You see what I'm saying?
And once we could get that in their head
they going to be so much better.
With life or anything you do.
Because these plays a part in everything.
It's just not one thing is everything.
- What advice would you give
to a young man who's considering
doing this kind of work?
- If he got a chance to
stay positive, like me
if I have never got
distracted with the streets
I probably would have been pro right now
and playing basketball.
You know what I'm saying?
But I got so distracted
and started smoking and
stop my Grove out and stop.
You know what I'm saying?
So if you got another way in
another way out, go for it.
Because anything about it
I hate to say nothing we doing right.
You see what I'm saying?
So anything you're doing wrong,
you know you got to look over your back,
and all that.
And that ain't what you want.
You want to be able to go
home and not have to look out
for nobody to worry about the
police doing this and that
everything just the right way.
So you got a chance to do better
and not want to be
around these and do that.
Get you a wife, start you a family
love them and do them right.
And go by them right,
and God will bring you so much more.
- If you're ever have to straighten out
some of your girls that get
headstrong or they get ideas
of their own, do you
ever have to rough them
up?
- Like, they get to spin on themself man,
if I get to telling them stuff
and I won't be aggressive man
they think that I'm getting
soft on them and all that.
So I have to rough them
up and let them know that,
nah, I ain't going soft.
I'm just giving you a leeway.
I don't have to be in your face
and doing these all the
time to make you do right.
If I speak these, no matter
what type of voice I use
if I bass in it or not.
If I speak it out my mouth,
this is what I want.
This one needs to be done.
You know what I'm saying?
It's simple as that.
- All right, man.
Thank you so much for
sharing your story and
talking with me.
- Yeah. Thank you, man.
Hopefully we meet again.
Thank you.